hey guys Peter Brown and mark Walton
here at e3 2014 mark you just saw
homefront revolution the sequel to a
game that left many people disappointed
well you know the original home front
you know mixed reactions that game
suffice to say some people didn't like
mechanics some people didn't like the
story but in this one you know they're
coming out and they're saying hey you
guys we've got a totally original idea
and an amazing story can you guess what
it is revolution yes yes you're right
it's in America yes it's in an American
city that's real yeah not San Francisco
North San Francisco but it is an
American city I know you're forgetting
the big one the big American city no no
no you forgetting the big theme of any
original video game story Koreans oh yes
yes yes cities Koreans for your for
forgetting about post-apocalyptic oh how
could I so essentially in this game yeah
Korea has invaded the United States
North Korea amazonas I guess so they
didn't smell hold something else in this
I'm like a nugget of thing that's
falling in Korea but essentially it's
career now ready to the United States
sat in Philadelphia after it's been
totally trashed everything's like I
really messed up and kind of crazy and
you all this one guy is trying to start
a revolution against government
especially and that is the clock game
and you sort would just start off from
there and you know start trying to kick
ass I guess so those are the the details
about the game but what are your
impressions of it so far it's
interesting because what they're trying
to do with this is say you're not like a
super high powered soldier guy okay
you're not like oh my god I'm so
beefcake I've got all these guns you are
like one guy in the middle of a
revolution okay so you're strange
enforce your not like something those
are shotguns and those alarma so you
have to like go to a little like
hideouts and little stores and try and
find what you can buy like scrounging
through cupboards and all that kind of
stuff and then you sort of make
makeshift weapons so you can like your
module weapons at any time you want do
stuff like that and one of the really
cool things that showed off was this was
in the stage demo as well but it was you
got a remote control car yeah band in a
cupboard and then you could mod it and
modded it to your attached like bombs to
it and stuff and then you pulled out his
mobile phone took it up and then control
the remote control car into a face blew
up blew it up remotely and then creator
distractions that you could go around
inside and do something else and like
flank the enemy it was very very good is
that sort of a representative of a
larger system in the game where you will
find these everyday items and put them
to use in ways that help you you know
complete your mission well absolutely
and there's the weapon the weapon
modding system is quite deep so whenever
you've got a weapon on you you can mod
at any time as you're walking around it
sort of flips over and all the different
components that you've got you can add
on to it okay home which is super cool
and there's also like use your mobile
phone for like reconnaissance and stuffs
and you take photos whether you can
light
I camp in targets your map and so like
there's like cameras dotted around you
can do that as well and then you get
homilies when you get sort of white
points for like doing something but
against the government so if you break
down like you get points for that and
that's sort of like your revered that
starts to ignite its revolution alright
so apparently we're gonna be earning
revolution points using remote
controlled cars and fighting the korean
alright alright so that was Mark Walden
on home from revolution to e3 2014 stay
tuned and GameSpot for more news from
the show floor